hi I'm Bethany I'm Bob we're best toast
and we're gonna talk about our favorite
YouTube videos okay so the first video
we're going to talk about is called DMX
rides slingshot Orlando hilarious why do
we love this video the voice of DMX is
great in anything he's like so nervous
before the flu shot goes off my favorite
part is like he launches and then he
holds onto his chain because his chain
starts like floating and he like grabs
it and he's like screaming and then like
once they like get to the top that are
like we did it and it's like very like
encouraging he conquered a fear so our
drummer Brady one day he showed me a
picture of this little furry guy it's
like who is this guy I'm obsessed with
him and I love Mexican wrestling and I
was like oh I know that is K monito like
what does he do like what's his deals
like he's kind of like a mascot for the
normal sized wrestlers and I was like
here I'll show you a video of him and
it's him getting dropkick we watch it so
many times it's just always the funniest
thing a Great Spirit lifter I don't know
why then what that says about as we like
seeing a little person get dropkick to
the floor but he's a trained
professional the next video is called
spider-man does I don't know do you know
how to pronounce this Jamo needed money
it's money it's like this really like
crappy fighter man costume like
Hollywood Boulevard style like work yeah
and next to him is like budget Mickey
Mouse and the little kids there's like
ghosts on
Ludacris was on Facebook and you read
all that god bless you Ludacris thank
you
well here's the best one of all time so
we picked a kind of an epically long
clip it's from the Metallica documentary
some kind of monster there's like bonus
feature discs and there's a part where
they show Metallica working with ja Rule
and Swizz Beatz on this like rock rap
song the song ends are being called yeah
we did it yeah we did they think it's
amazing but it's actually the like but
now we love it but yeah we know it's
kind of the best terrible but it's like
also incredible we did for the last
video we're going to talk about is
called the moment the keyboard comes in
wait for it Weezer fail I feel sort of
back laughing at this video but at the
same time it's really funny like these
little kids in a talent show at school
they're playing sweater song by Weezer
it's not the greatest rendition but God
blessed them for trying and the keyboard
player goes to play the Oh
the keyboard just collapses to the
ground and they all sort of just stop
and like you don't really know what to
do so they kind of just look and then
like very slowly like they start like
picking the keyboard up but it's just
something we watch a lot on tour you get
really bored on tour
if you feel shitty you just watch this
shitty YouTube video and then you feel
amazing we're sort of professionals in
the world of ridiculous YouTube